the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I wanted to use this final time our we
have together to summarize a few of this
what I take to be the central themes of
the course the the organizing ideas that
that then at least have seemed to me to
structure our our argument and our
progress through these Oh through this
almost a hundred years of movies the
first idea at one that we've come back
to I think again and again has to do
with what we might call film in its
anthropological or sociological aspect
film as a cultural form as an expression
of a culture as something that grows out
of a culture that expresses the values
and prejudices and weirdnesses of a
culture from this angle questions of
aesthetic value questions of artistic
excellence are irrelevant in some sense
within it from this angle we're thinking
about film simply as a as a central
expression as a central habit of culture
itself and we might we might recognize
that in the 20th century film where film
was the dominant narrative form the film
performed functions in the 20th century
that earlier forms of storytelling of
narrative and drama had played in
earlier cultures and one of my deep
desires in the course one of my implicit
ambitions all the way through was to
encourage you to think about movies in
this way as an as a as as an expression
of the values and assumptions of 20th
century cultures which might in earlier
times have been expressed in other media
and was I it was important for me to
have you recognize that our 20th and
21st century although it's somewhat
different in the 21st century because
films are film is undergoing such a
profound transformation in the digital
age nonetheless in the 20th and the 21st
century audio-visual narrative is a
dominant experience for virtue
everyone in the in the world in earlier
societies we had didn't have this option
but it didn't mean that the functions
played by the movies weren't played by
earlier forms so that's one of it that's
been one of the deepest umph shion's one
of the recurring principles to which
I've recurred through the through the
through the course and another aspect of
this idea something I've come back to I
think several times has been the
relationship between storytelling and
culture and what I've got drawing
especially on certain anthropological
and historical sources I've tried to
suggest to you that one way of
understanding culture itself is to
understand culture through its stories
is to understand that the stories our
culture tells reveal the culture in
basic ways not necessarily reveal the
culture at its best although sometimes
they may do so but they reveal the
culture in powerful and central ways and
some of our work in this course as I
hope you recognize has been an attempt
in some ways to to recover what might be
called the cultural or the
anthropological or the sociological
assumptions and beliefs that are
embedded in our movies one of the most
important aspects of this principle of
storytelling as intimately connected to
the progress of culture has to do with
an idea I suggested early in the term
the idea that culture itself and this is
one I think one of the great insights of
20th century cultural history cultural
analysis is the recognition that culture
itself is a completely unfinished thing
that it's never a single fixed item that
culture itself is society itself is
always in the process of evolving and
changing that it's that its idea of
itself is always in flux right this is
an immensely productive way of
understanding what society is because
what it allows us to do is recognize
that the various expressive and other
especially the expressive forms of a
culture play a central role in what we
might call this ongoing attempt of
scizor of a society to define and renew
itself
according to various values and
assumptions and historical inheritances
but also that the culture uses these
stories as a way to react to
disturbances and challenges to the
social fabric they remember borrowing on
the great English cultural historian
Raymond Williams I suggested it in
earlier course in earlier class that one
of the ways to think about this process
is to imagine culture itself as
consisting of sort of three strands or
voices an emerging voice which
represents new ideas the future right
emergent voices dominant or central
voices where the central values of a
society are embedded and articulated and
on the other side what might be called
traditional or vestige of voices the
voices or energies that are losing force
losing power as society changes that
belong to a past but are still part of
the mix and once we understand that
culture is this constant sort of ongoing
mixed conversation amongst traditional
dominant and emergent voices we begin to
understand much more about the
complexity of how a culture but proceeds
and it what and of course what this also
does once we make the link between the
stories of culture tells and the
cultures idea of itself we can recognize
that this same process can work for
understanding stories it's immensely
liberating immensely illuminating to
recognize that of course films like
other forms of narrative are going to
contain elements that are not completely
coherent not completely in agreement
that they actually may sustain
contradictions that that films that
films like other forms of narrative may
very well articulate both emergent and
traditional voices and those those two
voices may be in conflict or at least
not in perfect coherence in a particular
text so one of the advantages of this
perspective is to allow us to recognize
something of the complexity even the
dynamic and potentially partly
contradictory elements that we may find
in particular films the idea that
culture is always unfinished
never a fixed or finished thing and that
the stories of culture tells are a part
of this ongoing conversation
this dynamic always unfinished
conversation about the values and
assumptions the society lives by I
suggested a number of times that one way
to think about the central or the
dominant narrative forms in particular
cultures film in the 20th century the
novel in the 18th and 19th century in
certain European and America and in
American society the Public Theater of
Shakespeare's day the oral formulaic
narrative in the ancient world of Homer
and what I've suggested is that these
narrative forms might be labeled can
usefully be labeled as consensus forms
because they understand themselves to
occupy a central space in the society
that they recognize not necessarily that
they're expressing a true consensus no
society has a perfect consensus but that
what they recognize is that they're
expressive they're expressing what is
the imagined or the accepted or the or
the presumed consensus of the culture
that consensus of values may not be
bought into by everyone certainly won't
be nonetheless even the people who don't
accept the consensus values recognize
what the dominant values of the culture
are and recognize those sites like the
movies in the 20th century that are
carriers of what we might call that
official or consensus meaning and one of
the things I tried to suggest to you in
the in the course of our our discussions
is the way in which in the 20th century
form of film the way the central role
that genre forms play in this process
right the way and can you see why that
would be true one reason is that there's
an implicit in there's an implicit
principle of repetition within variation
in genre forms because they're so
familiar the different as one as a late
Western and an early Western might be
they're still westerns and they share a
great deal right they share certain
fundamental qualities that that every
viewer recognizes the more literate the
viewer or the reader is in the
conventions of a particular genre the
chair the uses of that genre become
especially as the genre elaborates
itself over time and one of the things I
tried to show you by talking especially
about the Western in American society
was to suggest that we can actually
understand some of these genre forms as
in some sense mirroring the debate of
society may very well be having about
its own nature and that the way the
Western changes over time you know in in
in the history of film is a kind of
distillation of this process whereby the
stories of a culture helped the story
help the culture to accommodate itself
to changes help them help the culture
figure out how its past and its present
can be brought into some kind of
relation help that help the society get
used to change and dynamic challenges to
its to its coherence one implication of
the of the kind of argument I've been
making about consensus narrative as I've
suggested a number of times is that
consensus narrative always what I'm
calling consensus narrative we might use
a simpler and less aggressive term we
might say various forms of popular
culture share the same qualities with
with the particular form of popular
culture I'm calling consensus narrative
and remember one of the exciting things
about this concept is it shifts from
moment - from a culture to culture or
from era to era the consensus narrative
system of one society won't be the same
as that of another Society but the
systems will share certain in one case
it might be the novel in another case it
might be the film but both systems will
both both of these forms when there are
consensus system consensus forms will
share certain qualities and I've
suggested that the central qualities
they would they share are that they are
always in some deep way conservative
right they're both morally conservative
or or conservative in terms of content
because they're trying to reach the
whole of the society and they have to be
careful about that they can't be as
advanced or as radical as the most
radical or or avant-garde parts of the
culture because certain elements of the
culture would be alienated by it and
it's the cultural
work of consensus narrative to address
the center of society right so they're
conservative in content and in moral
values and they're also conservative
artistically that is to say they don't
do a lot of sort of daring and and
shocking technical or structural
experiments again because they want to
be because they aim to be understood by
a large proportion of the population
they aim to be readable by everyone and
that brings us to to a second item
that's an aspect of always a fundamental
aspect of consensus narrative that
they're accessible that they are written
in or or created in a you know language
according to printing to archetypes or
stereotypes or shared tropes and and and
conventions that are accessible readable
to the whole of the society and a final
feature that these texts always have is
that they are collaborative that is to
say and I and I've suggested earlier in
the course that one way to think about
how collaborative the movies are is to
recognize that every movie is itself a
collaboration that you can't make a
movie one person can never make a movie
that a movie is always a collaborative
form but but I mean that this idea of
collaboration in a deeper way as well
not only is the text are the texts of
movies than literally collaborative
great collaboratively created by many
many creators but their collaborative in
another way and LA in a deep way and of
course the most obvious one is the way
in which Yan reforms
collaborate with themselves the way
they're in a kind of conversation with
all prior instances of the genre that's
a full and that what that means is that
Yan reforms are collaborating with their
history they're collaborating with their
path and they're also implicitly
collaborating with the audience's
literate knowledge of what these genre
forms are like how they behave what the
expectations and the more and their
collaborative in yet another way and and
and this this aspect of their
collaborative character is one that I
haven't emphasized too much and I want
to do it
today in our in our final in our
farewell lecture their collaborative
also because these texts in some deep
way are collaborating with what we might
call the collective wisdom or values of
the culture right and that this is
implicit in what I've been saying
about the way these story forms draw on
the histories and stories and
conventions that are most widely shared
and in a culture but I want to clarify
what I mean by it so there's that kind
of collaboration in which they're
constantly borrowing forms and arguments
and principles and symbols from the vast
body of shared knowledge that a culture
might have and so that but what this
might actually lead to or some what one
thing this leads to is the recognition
that these cultural forms are not always
Noble or wonderful that they carry
prejudices that they carry racism that
they carry misogyny that they're going
to embody that that that the that the
study of these Texas not as necessarily
it shouldn't that never should be a
totally celebratory experience even
though many of these texts are want
valuable and lasting and and speak to us
in deep and powerful and useful ways
it's also true that these texts carry
the lies and prejudices of the cultures
from which they come as I've said a
number of times in the course perhaps
too many times but there's a nut but I
meant but I mentioned again in in this
last lecture because I want to also
mention that there's a way in which not
just the evils and the limitations of a
society that get expressed in the in the
color in the in the collaborative
consensus forms that emerge from them
but also sometimes the wisdom of a
society does - in other words what I
want to suggest you is that the
collaboration has to do not only with
with with inherited values and inherited
beliefs and inherited story forms they
also have they also have to do sort of
with a cut whether with a cut with the
kind of inheritance of them of wisdom
and I have a particularly exciting way
of distilling this for you there's a
passage one of my favorite passages from
Shakespeare from his from his great late
play Cymbeline from act 4
- in which a group of characters gather
around a body they think the body
actually comes alive later in the play
because there's a lot of wonderful magic
in the play it's a play about Redemption
and rebirth but at this moment in the
play they think this person is dead and
they sing a dirge it's one of the most
uh dirt assault a funeral song a song a
song or a poem to be sung or recited at
a graveside and there's a maybe the
greatest of all such churches in English
is in Cymbeline and this is the first
stanza and the greatest stanza
fear no more right there people are
standing over a corpse right fear no
more the heat of the Sun nor the Furious
winters rages val by worldly tasks hath
done home art gone and taken thy wages
very interesting to me - to image to
embrace a metaphor of working of were a
working-class metaphor right you've got
you're dying when and the metaphor is
you've taken I what you you've taken
your last wages you've finished your
your work home art gone and taking my
wages and here comes the couplet that I
think is most powerful golden lads and
girls all must as chimney sweepers come
to dust let me say it again so you get
the whole stanza it's quite beautiful I
think fear no more the heat of the Sun
nor the Furious winters rages thou thy
worldly task hath done home art gone and
taken thy wages golden lads and girls
all must as chimney sweepers come to
dust now think about those last lines
for a minute they're very powerful even
if you don't exactly get them golden
lads and girls right
the implication is highborn wealthy
golden in their youth and in their
energy and in their and in their and
then in their vitality no matter how
golden whether in wealth or in vitality
even even golden golden lads and girls
end up in the grave like all of us and
there's a the implication of course is
there's a kind of consolation in the
fact that its death is our shared fate
there's a it's a console an attempt to
console us although the older I get the
less consolation they get but I I find
myself taking from this insight
nonetheless it is a great poem and the
stanza is a particularly remarkable poem
because of one element in it
the phrase golden lads for those of you
very few Americans know this but some
Brits know this
in Shakespeare's native Warwickshire the
phrase golden lad referred to something
very specific it referred to the
condition of the common ordinary flower
that we call the dandelion and it's a
it's a flower that that that has a gold
cap when it's when it's young and then
when it goes to seed and you've all seen
them because they're native to North
America as well as England they're the
the top of the cap
turns into a kind of rounded series of
filaments a beautiful round cap and get
when when you're a lot of children pick
them and blow them and you could the
seeds blow although one of the reasons
that these that these common weedy
flowers are so common is that they're so
they're so brilliantly designed by
nature to propagate because the wind
blows their their seeds all over the
place do you all have an image of this
so when they're young the flowers have
these golden caps and then when they go
to seed they become these rat they have
these rounded filaments on the top and
these rounded filaments in Shakespeare's
day were called golden lads when they
they were actually called these flowers
were called golden lads when they were
in bloom and they were called Chimney
Sweeps
when they when they went to seed because
they looked exactly like the chimney
sweepers broom chimney sweepers would
take these rounded brooms and put them
up in chimneys to clean them so when
Shakespeare writes in the in the end
there he says golden lads and girls all
must as chimney sweepers come to dust
he's describing literally the
raises of life in a flower why is that
wonderful can you see why that's
wonderful why that's what art is because
of course what's happened is that what
shakes we did was turning will create a
brilliant metaphor out of something
that's profoundly concrete right and but
but so the phrase golden lad and chimney
sweeper actually refers to the life
cycle of a flower we'll think of how
much more consoling how profoundly
brilliant the lines become when actually
Shakespeare's metaphor is literally
linked to the passages of nature to the
progress of nature right so what I'm
what I'm calling your attention to is a
brilliant piece of poetry is a piece of
poetry that has a kind of richness and
complexity that's all that that almost
couldn't be better
right I mean and even when we don't know
that about the flower we get the meaning
of the lines but think how the lines
come alive once we recognize that the
progress of human life in those couplets
is being explicitly associated with with
the life cycle of a natural object of a
flower right now this is a great act of
poet poetic genius isn't it but where
does the genius lie where does it come
experience collaborating with the wisdom
of his culture he it takes Shakespeare
to figure it out I mean I'm not saying
that it isn't an act of genius for
Shakespeare to realize the metaphoric
implications of this he did but the
metaphor is embedded in the way ordinary
people named that flower for hundreds
and perhaps thousands of years
Shakespeare is collaborating there with
the wisdom of his culture with the
shared understanding of his society in
order to make that brilliant line of
poetry so we can take the that idea that
the notion of golden lads as a kind of
emblem for the collaborative energies
that are sometimes released when artists
collaborate with the traditions of their
culture with the traditions of naming
with the traditions of understanding
that are embedded and so therefore the
collaboration is a deep one it's an
intellectual and a menace and a and an
expressive and a creative collaboration
between the societies understanding of
the of things of the cultures underst
ending of things and the artists
interaction with those that's an aspect
of an even deeper aspect of what I mean
when I say that consensus narrative and
that movies are a collaborative art form
I've also tried to suggest again and
again in the course that there are films
and many of most of the films we've seen
in this semester also deserve the
designation art and I don't want I've
not really wanted to turn the term art
into a kind of elitist category which
sort of in which we from which we must
sort of retreat in awe and bow before it
I want us to think of art in a simpler
and I think more useful way as a form of
intelligence and competence right in
other words when things are done well in
a work of art when the thing when when a
movie is well made when a poem is well
made we we admire it and we respect it
and we don't have to get mystical about
the qualities of art in order to
recognize that intelligence and
competence are are are qualities that
that we value in other aspects of
experience as well as in art itself and
what what do I mean specifically by
intelligence and competence the most
profound way of understanding this
argument has to do with what I've spoken
about a number of times in the course
I've sometimes used the phrase organic
form to explain what I meant in that in
this regard but essentially the idea has
to do with the sense with the
recognition that a serious artist will
use instruments that further his or her
intentions effectively and fully that is
to say that there's a connection between
the formal or stylistic choices that an
artist makes and the content that is
part of the artwork that is to say that
there's a that there's a link or a bora
ora ora or a connection between the
formal choices that a writer or a
filmmaker makes and the content intended
to be to be communicated from and we can
we can think of the term competence
having to do simply with wit with with
the idea of technical mastery in other
words a competent poet is a master of
language is a master of metaphor is a
master of grammar you can't be a great
poet if you have no understanding of
grammar or whatever because you'd be
you'd be throwing away one of the great
technical resources of the language
which is which is the group the
complexity that grows out of a mastery
of grammar by the same token you
couldn't have a serious filmmaker who
didn't have a deep profound sense of
what it meant to create a visual story
what it meant to try to embody meaning
in in audio-visual ways right you
couldn't have a great filmmaker who was
oblivious entirely to the visual nature
of his experience he'd have to eat yeah
the the filmmaker would the filmmaker
what any serious filmmaker has to be
always aware of the special qualities
and properties of the medium in which he
or she is working so if we think of art
then not as not as a mystical category
but as as as an expression of
intelligence and mastery intelligence
and competence perhaps we've demystified
it a bit and given us grounds for
actually making judgments about
particular films and particular passages
and moments in film and let me remind
you again that a second version of this
argument about the relationship of at
least in part about the relationship
between art and its and what what I had
sometimes called entertainment the
greater complexity or richness of art
can be embodied also not only in this
first principle of a connection between
the stylistic and formal choices and the
content but in this second way in the
second category or second perspective as
well in terms of what I've called
texture or multiplicity right the
multiplicity principles let me just
quickly remind you of a couple of
examples we've looked at in the course
just as a way of giving you some
instances from which you can look from
which you can extrapolate your your own
responses to other texts
do you remember for example the scene of
that that we that we looked at fairly
closely in McCabe and mrs. Miller that
disturbing ironic shootout on the bridge
in which a murderous young killer goods
a young farmer into taking the gun out
of his holster and shoots him down in
cold blood would simply remind you about
the way in which what Gaytan part of
what gave that scene its power
had to do with the fact that there was a
psychological dimension to it
the young murderer was committing the
murder had been frustrated because he
tried to show off earlier and not
succeeded and that imparted a terrible
horrible irony to the scene because you
realize that this boy this murder is
completely fortuitous it's completely
accidental if that if that little
murderer had succeeded earlier in
shooting the bottle that was floating
around on the on the frozen on the
frozen pond he probably would not have
child he definitely would not have
challenged this young farmer to try to
get back his mojo and show the people
around him that he knew how to handle a
gun so it made this is and and of course
that and then so that that already
created a kind of complexity and texture
but then when we add in the fact that
this scene itself is one of the central
iconic scenes in all westerns two males
stand with facing off against each other
ready to shoot we come to realize that
the I various anti-heroic and and ironic
ways in which this shootout is handled
throws a profoundly critical and
disturbing light on dozens and perhaps
hundreds of earlier such scenes that
have occurred in westerns that the very
basis of the westerns embrace of
violence its notion that you can achieve
regeneration through violence is put in
question by that scene so there's a
texture or multiplicity in the scene
it's not if forwards the story it shows
it shows a violent act it tells us
something about the psychology of the
murderer but even more than that it
resonates through the whole history of
the Western because the shootout itself
has been shown in such an anti heroic
such an ironic light texture
multiplicity remember the moment in
cabaret where the Joel gray character
the the interlocutor the the at one
point kneels down while he's talking and
during the mud wrestling scene and picks
up a piece of mud on his finger rubs it
on his face like this and gives a Hitler
gives himself a Hitler mustache I mean
it's a rich comic moment but isn't it
more than that especially in the context
of as the film proceeds we understand
from that moment that the Nazis are
objects of fun and mockery not that
dangerous it would seem at least that
the Cabaret feels superior to it and of
course when we think about the course of
the film when we think about how the
Nazis moved from the periphery to the
center of the movie we come to recognize
that that moment especially in
retrospect that moment has a particular
kind of ironic richness that's partly a
function of the obliviousness that
everyone in the Cabaret and even the
Joel Grey characters despite his
apparent cynicism and worldliness seems
to have about they were all they're
innocent they're naive about the power
and danger of the rise of the Nazis and
let me give you one last example
although there are many others that we
mentioned do you remember the moment in
the passage I showed you from from the
De Sica movie Umberto D that very brief
moment where we see a man get on a get
on a tram a bus and sit next to someone
on the bus and the bus moves there it's
a completely wordless sequence and
there's a character we've never seen in
the film before who sits down next to
the protagonist no words exchanged when
our protagonist gets up and gets off the
bus the camera lingers briefly on the
man he'd left behind and we see that man
go like this and what I suggested to you
was again I suggested that this was a
moment of richness and and and
complexity of multiplicity in a way
because one implication of that scene
was that the man this stranger that
we'll never meet again that we only saw
for one brief instant in the course of
the film might have concealed a story as
deep as rich and as moving as that of
our hero Umberto D who was now leaving
the tram and will shortly we will
shortly be following him so again a
moment of
laxity or richness that that embodies
central meanings in the helps us to see
central meanings in the in the text well
I have a final example of this kind of
texture or multiplicity it's an example
I had hoped to show you when we talked
about Kurosawa last week but I didn't
quite make enough time in my in my
lecture and I want to show it here as a
kind of final homage to that great
director and as a way of reminding you
of the variety of performances that the
great actor Toshiro Mifune who plays the
rapist in Rashomon was capable of so
here is a scene a very minor scene
actually from the film from the great
Kurosawa film Seven Samurai which I
mentioned last time let me set the
context for you before I show it to you
it's a very brief scene Seven Samurai
which I've sometimes shown in this
course I actually toyed with the idea of
having you watch both but they're both
Rashomon and seven samurai but Seven
Samurai is a very long movie and I
sometimes warn students about it when I
show it in the class I decided not to do
it but I hope all of you over the
Christmas break soon we'll look at Seven
Samurai it will resonate especially for
you it since you've just seen an earlier
Kurosawa film
well this immensely long film has a
wonderful epic amplitude and the long
first section of the film involves
essentially the assembling of a group of
samurai who are going to go to a village
to defend this village of farmers from
the depredations of bandits when the
film opens some farmers are make their
way to a great city trying to find
samurai who will come and defend them
and they're the and this the first
section of the film shows that the this
group of samurai slowly coming together
but only six of them are in the group
because there was a seventh who tried to
join them the Toshiro Mifune character
but he was rejected in
earlier part of the film that we haven't
yet seen that would that you that that
we have seen but when you look at the
clip you will not have seen yet because
he's not really a samurai he's he's a
he's a commoner who was trying to think
that he was a samurai he grew up top not
he can handle the sword but they could
tell in various ways he didn't know the
poetry that samurai knew a lot of ways
in which they figured out that the
Mifune character really was not a
samurai so they didn't let him join them
and in this theme we're going to say
it's two or two and a half minutes long
and this is one reason I wanted you to
look at it because it's it's so brief
and its basic function is so simple the
point of the scene is to get the samurai
to the village where the central aspect
with a where the central adventure of
the film will take place right so we can
almost think of part one as a kind of
prologue or or at least an introductory
preparation the film really isn't going
to get going in it in one sense until
after this transition moment there so
the sequence we're looking at it as a
very simple narrative function it's to
get the samurai from the city to the
rural village and we see them making
this trip but as you'll see the scene
has a much greater multiplicity a much a
much greater significance than simply
this simple narrative significance of
moving the actors to a new location here
we go and see he's following them in the
back there and they say go away
all right so I've seen a scene of
unexpected comedy right but what else
can you see how much is going on there
if we if we think about the scene for a
moment we can see okay the first
function of the scene is to get them to
the village right but it's a wonderful
example of the multiplicity principle it
seems to me okay it forwards the story
and in some simple sense but what does
it also do it defines the samurai in
some basic way first of all there's the
legitimate samurai have a sense of humor
and the they but even more than that
when we went as we're watching this
scene what do we see among other things
a wonderful very brief dramatization of
the conflict between man and nature
think of how raw that natural look those
natural environments are in that's in
that sequence and the extent to which we
also so that the the film itself is in
many ways a sub-theme in the film is the
relationship between human beings and
natural forces this scene implicitly
sets that theme up without doing
anything fancy or calling our attention
to it what else does it do it defines
the Mifune character really richly and
fully he's something of a clown isn't he
he likes attention he knew very there's
something deeply theatrical about him
see the way he he knew those that the
other samurai were watching him and then
when he when he caught but he's also
what else do we learn about he's
unbelievably competent he jumps in that
freezing water and he catches a fish
with his bare hands right and one
implication of the scene may very well
be that one of the things the muthoni
characters trying to do is show the
samurai how competent he is right and he
led you to see Ben Healy ends up leading
them to the villain of course you might
guess do you think he remains excluded
no of course not he ends up joining me
he is the Seven Samurai and becomes the
seventh as the film as the film goes on
so we do so
so the buffoon is nature is defined for
us in in in action more than in words we
have the theme of nature versus man
have the broader definition of the
nature of the samurai group itself and
we get an action that also moves the
story to a new location and exists this
is the one reason that I find this
example such a powerful one is that many
people watching this movie never even
remember this scene because it's hardly
even though it is very dramatic scene
isn't it
the fact is there are so many
astonishing dramatic visually memorable
scenes in the film that almost most
viewers who who don't have the advantage
of having this scene singled out for
them would never even remember it and
that's exactly why it's so valuable it
seems to me because it it plays a
relatively minor role in the film its
role in the film is fairly simple and
structural but even in that simple
two-and-a-half minute sequence a great
deal is going on it's a wonderful
instance it seems to me of what we mean
by texture or multiplicity if you're
aware of this principle when you look at
other forms of art not just films I
think you'll find your sense of what is
going on in a particular text or a
particular expressive form will be
immensely enlarged and I hope you apply
these ideas not just to movies in the
future but to other but to other forms
of expressive experience as well I also
at the end of this course as at the end
of every semester I'm afflicted by a
sense of gratitude that I can't always
fully Express to my students I've been
doing this for a long time I was
thinking as the class opened this
afternoon looking out at your faces I
real is one of the most amazing things
about being a professor is that your
basic clients stay young and they keep
you young they keep you young even
though they also in some ways make you
more and more conscious of the gap
between you and your students in some
respects I have no doubt that part of
what has made my career as a satisfying
one and certainly what has made me a
much much better teacher that I might
otherwise have been
has been the enthusiasm and welcoming
interest that I've felt from virtually
every student I've ever taught and
that's been especially true in this
course and it's been especially true in
this semester so I want to end then by
saying thank you in a way symbolically
I'd like to say thank you to the
students to the students I've been
teaching for more than 35 years at MIT
for whom you are stand-ins but most of
all I want to thank you
you make me teaching makes me feel
serious being able to introduce students
to these astonishing works of art has
always has always seemed to me to be a
privilege for which I was unable to
express fully my gratitude so thank you
very much have a wonderful life
you